[Funny Music]
Rodriguez: Since my childhood
I always wanted to invent something
Has an impact on millions of people.
Through user-targeted technology,
We see this achievable.
We can design great games
Attract children and help them develop their intelligence
And develop their skills every day.
Our company consists of a small team working in
The field of games ten years ago.
Our vision is to be a global company
Since we started our business.
The idea of ​​the first application appeared when
My niece asked me to apply the sounds of the animals.
Everything in the market was full of ads.
I shared my suggestion with the Panel that
We design our application for animal sounds,
But without ads.
When we launch the application,
We started receiving thousands of downloads every day.
As the first application to be launched, it was only in three languages.
But then, at the Google Learning Center,
People from around the world use the app.
We decided to translate the application into as many languages ​​as possible.
Our team consists of four members here in Argentina
We were working to establish the initial part of the projects.
But when we realized from the beginning
That we create a large and very strong team,
We started to recruit people from all over the world
To cooperate with us in the tasks of voice translation, translation of languages,
And interpretation.
In about two months,
We have released the application into 15 languages,
Our purchases have increased
By 300% in just 12 months.
Balloon: In order to reach the universal,
You should have a conception of all cultural aspects.
In our Animal Sounds product,
We offer pig,
In some specific countries,
Users asked us to remove the animal from the game.
After removing the animal specifically for those countries,
Our average rating has changed from 3.9 stars to 4.2 stars,
The result for us was really amazing.
Evaluations in the audit section are an effective tool.
In order to learn from your users forum,
We respond to them in the language of the original users
With the help of Google Translator.
As a result, we have seen a significant improvement
In user ratings.
In fact, all are 4.4 stars or higher
in the middle.
Rodriguez: Share more apps in the Google Play store
Is great for us,
So we can reach millions of people
Every month in different countries
In different languages.
We have recently begun work on translation of applications.
Prices are also of paramount importance.
Since we started, we have seen a 20% increase in our earnings.
Balloon: We realize that Papumba is like a bridge
Which connects children, parents and teachers.
All our products carry their design
The idea of ​​enhancing the capabilities of our young users,
It is very exciting to design a new product
We know it will make a difference
In many families and homes from all over the world
In order to prepare the future generation of adults in the best possible way.
[Follow-up music]